certains nombre d'habitants devant une
porsche souffrant de cette pathologie
tels que des réactions allergiques
sévères et de la couleur bien que ces
ceintures
on sait jamais quand le monde est sur le
point de changer les témoins rapportent
que ces symptômes sont apparus après une
grosse averse de pluie quand ça arrive
il faut être pris l'eau de pluie
il ya un virus tout en haut est ce qu on
est bientôt arrivé entre latins c'est
l'endroit le plus sûr qu'on puisse
trouver
je suis là pour arranger ça personne ne
doit trouver à sousse
c'est lui la clé
je viendrai vous rejoindre le plus vite
possible je te le promets
on attend depuis six ans ne reviendra
pas sortir d'ici
viennent avec nous ils savent où trouver
des vivres
et
il n'ya plus à tuer toute la population
car rares survivants ont contaminé tout
le monde sur leur passage avant de
crever la gueule ouverte
[Applaudissements]
tu l'as trouvé ce bunker avant le
coucher du soleil ma seule
résponsabilité crs mais si tu crois que
le monde est encore comme havre
non s'il vous plaît vous approchez pas
du tout la future mais vous êtes quoi
des animaux elle était condamnée à
l'instance et 15h et les temps
[Applaudissements]
te retourne le cerveau alors n'a rien à
[ __ ]
personne n'appartient à personne dans ce
canton
ce n'est pas une question de survie mais
d'espoir
[Musique]